what about jung do you think that he do
you think that he experimented with
hallucinogens
who carl jung because he knew things he
knows things that you just can't believe
anybody could know
we know he he spent a year in in taos
uh i'm i have a house in taos
and um that year is not documented but
he was experimenting with with the
mind-altering substances
psilocybin probably
was that before or after the red book do
you know i think the bread book came out
of that
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased to talk with
two people today
first with author brian c murra rescue
and then later in the discussion with
professor carl a p
ruck professor of classical studies at
boston university
mr marescu the author wrote the recent
book
the immortality key the secret history
of the religion with no name which was
published by saint martin's press
in 2020 that's the book here i read it
from cover to cover last month uh it was
as excitingly plotted as
dan brown's uh da vinci code which is
really saying something given that was a
best-selling
novel and this is actually a work of
adventure non-fiction
inquiry and scientific exploration all
compacted into something that was
extraordinarily readable mr
rescue graduated phi beta kappa from
brown university with a degree in latin
greek and sanskrit which clearly
prepared him for his later work
as alumnus of georgetown law and a
member of the new york bar
he's been practicing law internationally
for 15 years
about the book for 2000 years prior to
the birth of christ the ancient greeks
found revelation in their own sacraments
sacred beverages were routinely consumed
as part
of the so-called ancient mysteries
elaborate rites that led initiates
to the brink of death and beyond
adolescence others drank the holy wine
of donisius to become
one with the god in 1970s in the 1970s
scholars including dr karl rock claimed
that this beer and wine the original
sacraments of western civilization
were spiked with mind-altering drugs
in recent years vindication for the
disgraced theory has been
quietly mounting in the laboratory the
constantly advancing fields of
archaeo-botany
and archaeochemistry have been hinting
at the enduring loose use
of hallucinogenic drinks in antiquity
and with a single dose of psilocybin
the psychopharmacologists at johns
hopkins and nyu are now producing
powerful revelatory religious mystical
experiences in the lab but the smoking
gun
remains elusive if these sacraments
survived for thousands of years in our
remote prehistory
from the stone age to the ancient greeks
did they also survive into the age of
jesus
was the eucharist of the earliest
christians in fact a psychedelic
eucharist
the immortality key takes its readers on
an adventurous 12-year global hunt for
evidence
professor carl rock who will join us for
the latter part of the discussion is an
authority on the ecstatic rituals of the
god dioenesis
with the ethnomycologist r gordon wausau
and albert hoffman who discovered lsd he
identified the secret psychoactive
ingredient
in the visionary potion that was drunk
by the initiates at the illusionian
mysteries
in persephone's quest in theogens and
the origins of religion he proclaimed
the centrality of psychoactive
sacraments
at the very beginning of religion
employing the neologism in theogen
to free the topic from the pejorative
temptation for words like drug or
hallucinogen
so we're very much looking forward to
talking to professor rock as well
so hello brian thank you so much for
agreeing to talk to me today about your
book
thank you jordan it's it's an honor it's
good to see you doing well
oh thank you very much um i'm very much
looking forward to this discussion i did
find the book
uh well of substantive intellectual
interest
that's for sure for anyone who's
interested in the history of religious
experience it's it's quite the trip
let's say but
it was remarkably well plotted as well
it was a book that was
very dense with information but almost
impossible to put down and so that's
that's uh that's quite the thing to pull
off so and
why why did you do this how did you do
it
i'm still trying to figure that out
jordan to be totally honest
um it was my avocation i mean i wasn't
no one
was writing checks for me to fly to the
mediterranean and look at ancient
secrets
um it's not the thing that you do when
you're supposed to be a practicing
attorney raising children
um but this this bug got into me um i
guess when i was a teenager i was
studying latin and greek
with the jesuits at an all-boys school i
got a scholarship
uh to attend that school otherwise would
not have afforded to go
and then was recruited by brown as you
mentioned to study latin and greek and
piled on some sanskrit some arabic
and other things in between and along
the way you hear about this best-kept
secret in history that's what um
houston smith perhaps one of the
greatest religious scholars of the 20th
century that's how he referred to these
mysteries
and particularly the sacrament within
these ancient mysteries these um
these sacramental potions that have
since gone missing you know for a couple
thousand years we've been trying to
crack this mystery to no avail
but there's houston smith saying it's um
it's a mystery worth investigating and
so i don't really know what to do with
that
in the late 90s and early 2000s there's
not a lot of scholarship
on ancient pharmacology and i read this
crazy book the road to ellucis which
comes out in 1978
and i'm trying to figure out how the
ancient greeks could have consumed
you know a beer otherwise spiked with
lsd
but there's no hard scientific data to
support it so i leave it to one side
until 2007 and it was roland griffiths
who you recently talked to
it was his early studies with psilocybin
the active compound and magic mushrooms
that began in the early 2000s the
initial results are released in 2006.
doesn't come onto my radar until 2007
but what i'm reading about
are people today modern day volunteers
having a transformative experience
from one and only dose of psilocybin
and gordon wassen is mentioned in the
first line of this article the god pill
and it immediately reminds me of the
road to ellucis and it and it reminds me
of ellucis itself 2500 years ago and
this this notion
um that it was a once in a lifetime
psychedelic encounter
that was very much part and parcel of
the origins of western civilization so
from there let's start let's talk about
the illusionian mysteries to begin with
clue everybody in about about
about what they were and why why you
believe and
what not just you obviously by but why
why they're of
of uh enduring significance both to us
now but also
you make the case in the book that the
very
essence of greek civilization from which
so much of our civilization
is derived was rooted in these
hallucinogenic mysteries essentially or
at least in the elusivian mysteries
and so so please elaborate on the
mysteries and their significance
so so we say the ancient mysteries there
were lots of mysteries in the ancient
world the mysteries of elusive the
mysteries of dionysus the mysteries of
isis and osiris but elusive
which today is this relatively small
town of only about 30 000
thirteen miles northwest of athens uh
for about two thousand years it was kind
of the epicenter
of the mediterranean spiritual universe
um it was not a sideshow
i sometimes referred to it as the real
religion of the ancient greeks and and
the best and brightest among them it
called to initiates like plato
um pindar cicero who actually called it
the most divine thing that athens ever
produced the most divine thing
so not democracy the arts and sciences
and philosophy um but ellusis
um marcus aurelius famously rebuilt
elusive when it was almost destroyed
uh so it it mattered to these people
both
your case in the book like you're you
make
you lay out your belief that
the illusionian mysteries were
absolutely central to the animating
spirit of greek civilization so it
wasn't rationality versus
the mysteries of dionysius let's say it
was rationality embedded in some more
profound uh
religious experience that was integrally
related with whatever was happening in
illicit
um absolutely integral and and we can
say that with a straight face and very
confidently because of the way its
destruction
is recorded in the 4th century a.d under
the newly christianized roman empire so
at the time
in the fourth century the roman emperor
valentinian tries to get rid of elusive
and we have the testimony of this high
priest pritek status
who says literally that life in the
absence of elusives
would be unlivable abbiotos in greek
and so there's lots of ways to translate
that or interpret that
but even carl cadeny this famous
classicist writing in the 1960s he looks
at that language and says
you know the sharpness of this
formulation that life is unlivable
without the mysteries
has no precedent in greek literature
even carl doesn't know what
what to make of this um and he draws a
distinction
with young current as well exactly
exactly exactly right
published with bollingen yeah very
impressive scholar and this impressive
scholar didn't know what to make of this
testimony from practice tattoos and he
thinks that practice status
is clearly drawing a distinction between
what was available in the pagan
mysteries
versus what was available in the rise of
christianity at that time
in the fourth century so again ellucis
is bound up not just with the notion of
greek
existence but human existence and the
survival of our species
okay so back to you as a teenager now
you got interested in this when you were
very
relatively young what why how what was
calling to you do you think
um uh it's it's that perennial search
for meaning
i mean um i was a very particularized
derivative of it though so i'm
there's some story there there's
something going on there that because
it's
as you also pointed out in your
introduction what you did is not
um it's not within the realm of
normative behavior you have your law
degree you have your family you have
your children
you're a sensible educated person and
you took a 12-year hiatus to pursue
something that that's very um
abstract spiritual historical there's
something driving you for sure and and
then you related it back to your teenage
years
what was gripping you and and because
there's part of that's the animation
spirit animating spirit of this book
okay so i mean if if i'm being honest
you know i was the first person in my
family to go to college
um and the whole reason i went to
college was because of latin and greek
there's there's no doubt about it um i i
may not have gone if it weren't for the
classics um or the jesuits
who were teaching me these classics and
for me this is a major identity crisis
and i talk about our societal crisis you
know um
our loss of connection with that
tradition well
exactly and i wanted to know what that
tradition was and how my catholicism
i went to catholic school for 13 years
how does my catholicism
and everything i've learned about the
christian lineage how how does that
square
with ellucis for example how does that
success that's something i really want
to talk to you about because
there is some transformation even if the
christians were using the
hallucinogenic sacraments that you
characterize as being
typically used by archaic greek
society which which i think there's some
reason for the christian trans
transformation and and i don't
understand the relationship between that
and
and the and the hallucinogenic story so
i would definitely like to return to
that but
okay so you're interested in greek and
latin and how you're the first person in
your
household to go to college how did you
get interested in greek and latin
um it was forced upon me uh by by the
jesuits latin was mandatory
at this school st joe's prep my
otherwise wouldn't have taken a shine to
it and then greek was an elective
but i stuck with that and um my
professor dr henry v
bender insisted that i stick with it
actually helped me apply to college
hopped me on a train
to go up to providence to brown to check
it out and and that that that that's how
it happened
um you know i wasn't touring colleges
with my family it was it was it was the
jesuits
who who got me thinking about this stuff
and and actually to their credit
very open-mindedly encouraged me to ask
very fundamental questions about the
origins of the faith and this whole
pagan continuity idea that we can talk
about this transference
from the pagan world to the christian
world and what it all means
and the interest in the hallucinogenic
element of it
what was that was that a consequence of
your knowledge that
something was being used as a sacrament
some some substance was being used as a
sacrament
adolescence in particular or is there
more to it than that
so this is the great irony is that i've
never experimented with psychedelics
um that's that's the great irony of this
book and all this research
because it really was roland's work at
hopkins
that just it hit me like a punch in the
face the idea of
um people experiencing psilocybin and
over the course of a few hours
having their lives completely
transformed you know not just um
positive changes and attitudes behaviors
and belief but
fundamental psychological change in an
afternoon
if i had to come up with a definition of
elusive that would be it
except it wasn't so you saw the
connection you you but but it wasn't a
consequence
of personal experience it was a
consequence of intellectual realization
that's what it was and those numbers uh
have stayed consistent roland will tell
you when i asked him before publishing
the book if this number still
makes sense uh he will tell me that 75
of these volunteers will report that
their one and only dose of psilocybin
remains one of the most meaningful
experiences of their entire lives if not
the most meaningful experience and this
is data going back 20 years now
okay okay so so so this provided you
with
with some insight into what might have
been going on
with the ancient mysteries and of course
there's there's other scholars who
pushed in in towards that conclusion
let's say
like dr rock who we're going to talk to
later gordon wasson for example
who who's mentioned continually in your
book yeah made the claim that
the amanita muscaria mushroom was the
soma of the
ancient hindus and was the was the
inspiration for the rig veda and
um uh mercedes who worked with karen
yeah and also with jung
wrote a great book on shamanism i i
don't know if you're you know the book
you
you likely do but eliade claimed that
the use of hallucinogens among shaman
the shamanic
practitioners was a deviation from the
historical norm
but i think the bulk of the evidence
that's been accrued since
iliad wrote his great book because it is
a great book shamanism it's a great book
um i think he was wrong about that i
think it's absolutely crystal clear that
throughout human history for at least 50
000 years perhaps longer than that
our spiritual guides especially in the
archaic world were using
whatever hallucinogenic substances they
could get their hands on with their vast
knowledge of
local biology to produce these mystical
experiences and we have
no idea to what degree that shaped us
culturally
or how that shaped our
uh our religious structures beliefs
presumptions all of that
and and so that would make elusive a
continuation of the shamanic tradition
and so i think it fits nicely into the
anthropological literature in that
manner
okay so on to on to your voyage you go
to brown
and just and study latin and greek and
so forth and
and then what happens and then i have a
great time learning latin and greek and
then i'm a senior
and i hear all the grad students
grumbling about the job market because
there is no
livelihood to become from classics i
mean it was either for me it was either
becoming a priest or a classics
professor and i still remain interested
in both oddly enough
but i took a left turn into law school
and decided to enter the marketplace and
to acquire you know marketable skills
it was it was largely an economic
decision
and despite going to law school you also
went on this decade-long hiatus
well because i couldn't put it down i
mean when i was you know um
even when i was when i was interviewing
for the law firm we wound up talking
about sanskrit because that's obviously
on my resume and people wonder why the
hell i wrote a senior thesis
translating a 13th century giant poem
from sanskrit and it comes up in
conversation
people find it mildly interesting and so
you go off from there
the the liberal arts have a way of
preparing you for all kinds of things
and in my case it was you know i would
still read latin and greek on my on my
lunch breaks and that that's what
drove the imagination until 2007 when
psychedelics came on my mental radar and
propelled me on this journey for another
12 years
all right well let's walk through the
journey tell us what you did first
well um i used my law firm salary to
purchase
every book that ruck himself had ever
written um and wassen and hofmann
then i started reading about terence
mckenna quite a bit and was reading his
information
and listening to his lectures and i
spent most of the day doing that for a
couple years
and then i started to realize that some
newer disciplines like the archaeobotany
and archaeochemistry that you mentioned
earlier
and with the advance of technology new
tools new techniques
we were suddenly able to peer back into
history in a way that we never could
before
in other words things like gas
chromatography mass spectrometry
and these wonderful you know lab
editions had allowed us to look into to
peer
into these ancient containers these cups
and these chalices and these grails
of sorts um and tell us for certain
relatively certain what our ancestors
were consuming and why and this is all
relatively new this is not this did not
exist in 1978
and so that was a big break for me in
this in this research trying to you know
attract the hard scientific data
to prove this one way or the other you
spent a lot of time in the book writing
about beer for example
and they've been making case too that
one one of the motivating factors for
the development of agriculture was
likely the easily
easy transformation of barley into
alcoholic beverage which or perhaps not
just alcoholic
but i thought that was also a very
interesting speculation
so maybe we can talk about that a bit um
it's mainly because i like beer and it
was a great excuse to go to germany to
talk to a beer scientist
to talk about beer which was a lot of
fun and beer could go back 12 000 years
as a matter
of fact beer might be responsible for
the birth of civilization
as we know it if you look to gobekli
tepe for example
about 10 years ago there was some
evidence from this giant
you know site of megalithic architecture
sometimes described as as the world's
first temple
um turns out the world's first temple
might be the world's first bar
in this giant megalithic site this by
the way is
six thousand years before stonehenge
seven thousand years before the high
civilizations of egypt and sumeria
but in this site they did find initial
traces of calcium oxalate which points
to beer fermentation
um and you know at the time might be
safer to drink some beer versus some
some some water in some cases and so it
could very well be the case that beer is
bound up
with these ancient sites with ancient
ritual um these t-shaped pillars meant
to be the depictions of early gods
um it's possible that there was some
intoxicating affair there we don't know
for certain
but you know beer could go back an
awfully long way right well we do think
of beer as a spirit
an alcohol as a spirit and that's not
accidental because it's the ingestion of
a substance that changes you
psychologically and so
it's not that great a leap to pause it
that there's some spirit that inhabits
the beverage
and that's the spirit of wine that's the
spirit of drunkenness dionysius you talk
about ergot
and its relationship to beer
manufacturer as well and
ergot is a is a a fungus
it's a fungus that produces an lsd like
substance
and so you speculate and and some of
that's backed up by the
the archaea botany that you described
that
perhaps beer was accidentally
contaminated with her good to begin with
but the consequences of that were
non-trivial to say the least
um it could be and this this was the
hypothesis put forward in this book the
road to elusive so this this was the
idea
that wasson hofmann and ruck had
stumbled upon and i think i largely
credit albert
who famously discovers lsd from ergot
right so he synthesizes lsd
from this natural fungus which contains
lots of other alkaloids by the way
um so things like lsa lsh etc
um to this day we don't know which
alkaloid it may have been that spiked
this beer potion um but could very well
have been something like an
ergotized potion that was consumed by
these initiates
century after century to you know open
the gates of death
and and convince them of their
immortality um this was the idea in 1978
and so
um i ran with that hypothesis and i
looked for ergot anywhere i could
in the in iliad's um description of the
shamanic
transformation he describes
and this is analogous to your
description of the
ellucinian mysteries trip and its
association with death okay so one of
the things we should point out
just to begin with is that roland
griffiths
gave psilocybin to cancer patients who
were facing death
and that transformed their relationship
to death itself
now when ellie added details out the
shamanic experience he said that the
shaman
who undertake their ritual
likely with the use of hallucinogenic
substances
are typically reduced to
something resembling a skeleton so they
undergo a death
uh and the nature of that experience is
not precisely clear
iliad never experienced it so these are
accounts that he derived from
the anthropological literature and the
shamanic culture stretched
perhaps all the way around the world
because there are uh
analogs between shamanic reports in from
siberia and from the amazon jungle so
it's conceivable that
that was all disseminated from a single
source or maybe maybe it's a consequence
of the fact that hallucinogenic
substances produce the same effects
worldwide
or maybe both who knows but in any case
the shaman die
they commune with their ancestors they
commune with their ancestral spirit
they climb the ladder or tree or
rope or pole that links the
domains of existence together so they
climb up this pole
into heaven where they commune with the
gods and that's the classic shamanic
experience
it's like jack and the beanstalk it's
and i believe jack and the beanstalk is
actually a very it's a
it's a it's a carryover from from
shamanic tales i think
it looks like it if you if you look at
the story carefully but any case there's
this
there's a death and then a rebirth
that's associated with the experience
there's a communion with ancestral
spirits
um the spirits of the forefathers let's
say there's the transformation of that
into something resembling communion with
god
and then the transformation of people's
understanding of death now i don't know
what happened to
um griffith's subjects that re that
transformed their understanding of death
in relationship to their cancer because
the research reports don't contain much
in terms of description of content of
experience right
it's not like people are magically
transformed something happens to them
in in the as a consequence of an
extremely packed and dense
experience that's all condensed into a
very very short period of time
and they come out while neurologically
transformed they showed transformations
and personality they're quite profound
even a year later
many of them quit smoking different
studies which also indicates a kind of
transformation even on a
a pharmacological level so back to
eloises
there there's something going on that
you talk about death and facing death in
lysis
and yeah it's the classic shamanic
journey i mean roland's volunteers
will sometimes talk about experiencing
their psilocybin journey as a
foreshadowing of death
um and again we don't know all the
details all the content um
but it's something like this is what
death will be like is one of the
overarching
conclusions and that was the mysteries
um again if
i have to put it in a few words it is
essentially a ceremony of death and
rebirth
um your words at the beginning of the
book
are um let me just get this here
from from the greek if you die
before you die you won't die
when you die and that certainly has
christian overtones as well
interestingly enough that comes that
comes directly from a plaque
at the saint paul's monastery on mount
athos in greece one of the holiest sites
of orthodoxy
it's very christian it's also very greek
going back to that you know
personality struggle i was talking about
are we greek or are we christian like
the old narrative is that
the greeks who invented all this stuff
democracy the arts and sciences etc
these rational people somehow you know
birthed civilization into existence but
then
christianity comes along and saves our
soul
but here's ellucis is the
contraindication ellusis
was the place where these initiates went
to find meaning
by dying before they die in some sense i
mean experiencing the
the same underworld journey as the
goddess persephone they identified with
her
not in any symbolic or metaphorical way
but something
visceral happened to them in an
experience yeah well
those myths those myths look like
they're reflections
they're narrative narratized reflections
of
an experience that that that people
actually went through and that
that journey to the underworld is to the
is a journey to the land beyond death i
mean it's more than that because
it's a metaphor as well as perhaps the
description of some kind of experiential
reality and we can't
we certainly can't probe it particularly
deeply
we don't understand what these chemicals
do we don't understand the
meaning or the or the reality the
significance of mystical experience of
this sort
but it is very interesting to note that
the people who
it it's very interesting to note that
the people who gave birth to our
civilization so to speak or at least
certain aspects of it
regarded this experience with a
tremendous amount of respect they didn't
feel it was something antithetical to
what they were doing they felt that it
was something that was nourishing what
they were doing
right plato calls it the holiest of
mysteries and talking about ellucis
aristotle says that
you go there not to learn something he
uses the greek word methane like
mathematics you don't go there to learn
something
but to experience something um and if
you think about philosophy in its
broadest sense plato himself says that
you know those who engage
with philosophy in the right way
practice nothing else but
dying and being dead so again it's it's
this constant sense of death
and rebirth something fundamentally
life-altering happens at a losses that
convinces these people
right um convinces these initiates that
they have
transcended their mortality and they are
guaranteed an afterlife it was said only
those who go to elusive only them
will experience the afterlife
well they i suppose they experienced it
when they went to a loyalist and then
perhaps had it with them for the rest of
their life at least that's that's the
that's the idea so so take us on some of
your trips you
you went to to talk to the world's
leading
beer scientists so to speak you went to
greece you went to rome
you you went to the vatican you went to
the vatican libraries what was that like
and what did you find there and how were
you received
[Laughter]
with relatively open arms um i i made
decent friends with the archivists and
the librarians largely over strong
italian coffee so that that's always a
tip
for your future vatican yeah well it's
so interesting that you didn't meet a
lot of resistance to what you were doing
because you'd think that
now is that because people didn't
understand what you're doing or did they
understand and let you anyways because
it's not that obvious that the vatican
would be that thrilled with the
proposition that
the original sacraments of christianity
were the most potent hallucinogens that
we know
and it isn't obvi and what sort of
response have you got from
from classically religious people
traditionally religious people
christian people most particularly as a
consequence of
laying out the claims that you've made
it's been somewhat surprising to be
totally honest
um in that there's been a generally good
reception
amongst the catholics and the orthodox
and the protestants with whom
i talk and and i think if you take a
step back and just think about it um
you know i'm not impugning anybody today
this is all ancient history
um a lot of it has been gone over well
before me i mean just just the notion
of other forms of christianity
gnosticism for example
uh those 52 books of the nag hamadi
corpus that were discovered in 1945
we've been
talking and writing about them for for
decades so i mean it's known that there
were other versions of the faith
out there you know throwing a
psychedelic twist in there is somewhat
controversial but
you know that would presuppose that
christianity
and and psychedelics are somehow
mutually exclusive and i'm not sure that
they are i mean even today
if you look you wouldn't be so convinced
of that if you read the book of
revelation
which looks for all intents and purposes
like like the account of a
hallucinogenic experience
um and so does some of the language in
the gospel of john or or so does
you know the mark for example in 4 11
might not be psychedelics when but when
jesus is asked why he speaks in parables
you know why talk about the mustard seed
in the prodigal son why not speak
plainly to people
the response from jesus is that he's
trying to relay a musterion
and that's the greek word for mystery
the very same mystery
as you would use in the mysteries of
elusive for example or the mysteries of
dionysus it's that word which
if you look at the the the thayer greek
english lexicon of the new testament
published in the 19th century they will
define that mustadion
in mark as a religious secret you know
confide it only to the initiate it
not to be communicated by them to
ordinary mortals i mean so the idea
that christianity is born with secrets
right
um potentially secret rituals i think
has been known for
for for some time i think that the big
question is whether or not that included
some kind of ancient pharmacology
yeah well that's definitely the big
question and the other big question of
course is what relevance does that have
to a church that increasingly seems to
be dying at least in the west
i mean i rick griffiths told me that um
a harvard divinity school is thinking
about
about starting up a psychedelic
psychedelic divinity program
yeah and i actually had a great talk
with charlie stang at harvard divinity
uh he interviewed me and grilled me
um in a very respectable way but he's
had a
a year-long series of wonderful
presentations on psychedelics and the
future of religion
um which which i hope will will continue
so of all places you know where
the the same campus that that spawned
timothy leary and dick albert
uh seems like there's there's some
interest in this again in a very sober
way
yeah so to speak so to speak yeah okay
so let's let's go to
let's go to the vatican what did you do
there in rome and what did you discover
well i discovered a version of the faith
like we've been talking about that
i didn't i didn't hear about in my 13
years of catholic school
um and i was investigating this notion
of continuity pagan continuity
the the idea that if there were these
psychedelic rituals in antiquity
in pagan antiquity did some of that
somehow make its way
into the christian world and um so i
went i went spelunking i went literally
under the vatican
into the necropolis atop which it sits
and went to
mausoleum m inside the vatican and right
there
um you know under the the cathedral you
will see the vines of dionysus
painted onto this this mosaic could be
one of the earliest christian mosaics
that we have as a matter of fact
in this tomb and art historians point
out that clearly these are the vines of
dionysus
that have been co-opted as the vines of
christianity
in john's gospel jesus refers to himself
as the true vine i mean so it's it's a
very kind of just silly example
of how you know the the edifice of the
church is
in some sense is literally built on top
of these pagan roots and if you go to
you know other catacombs around the city
under the streets of rome you will find
frescoes
from the third and fourth century and in
these frescoes you will see women
consecrating what looks like wine in
what looks like
some kind of version of a proto mass or
a proto-eucharistic meal
the vatican itself identifies these
women
as you know participating in a
eucharistic vigil
uh not what you often hear about um next
to one of these women consecrating one
you'll see the greek witch
cersei who if if anything is known for
her pharmacological expertise
going as far back as homer so it's
difficult to explain
these images these very greek images
that somehow reference pharmacology
somehow reference the the role of women
and the birth development of the church
it's not a christianity that's often
talked about so
why do you think if if christianity or
at least some branches of christ
okay so first do you think that
christianity itself had its origins in
hallucinogenic use i mean that's
certainly what john allegro claimed
right with the
mushroom and the cross i read that when
i was pretty young 15 and i had no idea
what to do with that book i mean
because there was no way i could
criticize it he was a philologist
essentially right he derived almost all
of his evidence from the derivation of
words from the
etymology of words and i just still
don't have enough expertise in that
field to
um evaluate his claims but i read that i
thought
christianity originated as a
hallucinogenic mushroom cult really
that's actually possible and
he compiles a tremendous amount of
evidence it's a very scholarly book it
destroyed his career
um because it was published at the
height of the hippie revolution which
timothy leary was responsible for and
as a consequence i would say of his
carelessness more than anything else
but allegro is very serious it's a very
serious book but it's not one that's
easy to
it's not easy to know what to do with
that book
and allegra was put aside because of it
and lots of people paid the price for
this and and rock who we're going to
talk to later was
was one of them as well i mean the book
the pathway was laid for you in some
sense because all these other people had
already suffered for putting forward
this hypothesis earlier right and so
i'm the first i had i had it easy jordan
there were there was there was no hard
going here which is at least maybe part
of the reason
why i was welcomed into the vatican or
why i've had great conversations with
people at harvard
and yale and elsewhere because because
times have changed i think largely
thanks to roland griffith's clinical
work
and and the extraordinary promise that
is being
shown on clinical depression anxiety
end-of-life distress ptsd addiction you
name it
with these compounds the the study of
which was interrupted for decades and i
think people
you know are beginning to to realize
that there's something here worth
looking at when the front page of the
new york times earlier this week is
talking about the future of psychiatry
um being revolutionized um because of
psychedelics was psilocybin right and
the same
sort of thing occurred in the early
1960s when lsd
and and and mescaline and and all of the
powerful psychedelics were being
uh utilized partly for the treatment of
alcoholism for example
and there was some evidence that that
was successful but things got out of
hand very very rapidly
i mean maybe that's why christianity
as it formalized put the psychedelic
sacraments to rest i mean
when we introduced them back into our
civilization speaking as a
you know westerner so to speak i mean
that was only in the 1950s when when did
it was wesson who went into
mexico and discovered the psilocybin
mushrooms and brought them back
he's quite the character i'd recommend
that everyone who's listening read about
gordon wesson because he was quite quite
the person
pulled these powerful hallucinogens back
into our culture i mean
they blew us into pieces in the 1960s so
badly we had to make them all illegal it
scared the hell out of everyone
well so to speak maybe it didn't scare
the hell out of everyone that would have
been the positive outcome but
that we are our authorities certainly
regarded them as
radically disruptive and that seems to
me to be not such an unreasonable
judgment even though
there's a counter very powerful counter
argument to be made but
it's something to be very very cautious
about are you
still a practicing christian and you
don't have to answer that i i want to
put you on the spot
i'd love to um i i very much still
consider myself
a christian in the way i learned about
it from the jesuits was
largely about social justice and
contemplative mysticism
and being of service i was taught to be
a man for others and in that sense yeah
i still consider myself
a christian maybe even more so after
discovering
um you know the pagan roots of this
faith and and what what i do think
is an interesting way for christianity
to sit
with these mystery traditions and the
possibility that in these early
centuries of paleochristianity there was
a type of christianity
um that clearly attracted people and i
think it's the kind of christianity that
that attracts me
today two thousand years later this this
notion of um
personal direct experience of the divine
something was happening
in those centuries to turn this
carpenter's son
into the most famous human being who
ever lived something was happening for
this
illegal cult um of a dozen or so
illiterate day laborers
to convert the entire roman empire in
only a couple centuries
and become the world that's also the
great mystery that's in your book too
because
the the loose indian mysteries are going
along for 2000 years let's say
and then they're disrupted and
christianity comes along and there's
a hallucinogenic end to it so what was
it about
what happened something happened that
that isn't
merely a continuation of the psychedelic
the shamanic psychedelic tradition or
that's
that's what you have to think if you're
a christian but that's also what you
have to think historically because
christianity did do exactly what you
said it did and so that's something i
can't
i'm very interested in this con con i'm
very interested
in christian ideas i'm very interested
in the continuity of religious
experience across tens of thousands of
years and maybe more than that
and i don't understand at all what
constitutes the shift that occurs from
the transformation from
the pagan structures let's say
predicated as they might have been on
hallucinogenic experience then extending
way back into
the shamanic depths of time god only
knows how long
there's some transformation though
that's specific to christianity that's
tangled up with the hallucinogen use
that i don't
understand at all and that has something
to do as well with this idea of the
defeat of death
and the rein and the resurrection of the
body and all of this
mystical elements and and and the and
the hallucinogenic elements of
christianity that are integrated into
the book of revelation and so on
so there's a pharmacological story but
there's a story of
the transformation of religious ideation
that also is a complete mystery i just
why was christ able to displace
dionysius let's say
and what does it signify that that was
the case
that's the i mean that's what i'm trying
to figure out i mean i think i think
allegro kind of sits on the more extreme
end of the spectrum of the psychedelic
hypothesis so i i mean i don't think
that the religion begins as a mushroom
cult for example
i'm not sure if there were psychedelics
at the last supper i think the
the the hypothesis i'm pursuing is
whether or not
there could have been you know some
communities of early greek-speaking
christians
who at some place in the ancient
mediterranean
would have availed themselves of some
kind of mind-altering sacrament
um you know the the the prevalence of
that kind of tradition we simply don't
know at the end of the book i say
it's probably not a majority there were
other things that led to
the rise and success of christianity uh
it's it's often
distinguished from its pagan
predecessors by this this sense of
community and love and charity
um that the ancient sources talk about
but but clearly
there there was something else um that
was inspiring people to
abandon the faith of their ancestors
perfectly good religion like elusive by
the way
which survives all the way through the
early christian period the mysteries of
dionysus a perfectly good religion
to the greek speakers of greece and
elsewhere that survives
before during and after the life of
jesus so
i think for at least some of these
communities the way the gospel was
communicated to them
in the greek language may have reminded
them
of some of these mystery rights some of
these pagan rituals well that is that is
a that is a
relatively speaking a very moderate
hypothesis i guess
the problem i have with that hypothesis
in so far as i have a problem with it
because
it could well be accurate is that as you
have pointed out the hallucinogenic
experience is so unbelievably powerful
that it's hard to believe that it
would have had it like a tremendous
impact and you see
also these these odd correspondences
between the development of christian
ideas and and
the the mysteries of facing death that
you described that aren't trivial so
christ is crucified he dies
three days later he so he spends time in
the underworld he spends time in hell he
resurrects that's a
that's a dying that's a death and
resurrection story that's very much akin
to
a shamanic death and and and rebirth and
it's it's hard to believe that those
ideas aren't in some manner
integrally related especially given that
that's something that can be experienced
as a concept
consequence of chemical transformation
and then the next question is
what the hell does it mean that that
sort of thing can be
um initiated in people re
repeatedly and reliably as a consequence
of chemical manipulation
i mean and you'd say well it's an
aberration it's a form of poisoning
that's a reason that's the most
reasonable hypothesis but then you'd
expect that if it was a consequence of
poisoning that the downstream effects
would be negative not positive and
i read a large scale study hundreds of
thousands of people it's retrospective
analysis
looking at the comparative mental and
physical health of hallucinogen users
versus non-users and on virtually every
measure of physical and mental health
the hallucinogen users
were healthier it's not what you'd
expect if it's poison
and so it's not poison but it's a
chemical that produces this incredibly
powerful spiritual experience what the
hell are we supposed to make of that
and and it's it's at the foundation of
our religious belief
historically speaking perhaps at the
foundation of christian ideas themselves
it looks like it's integral to the
emergence of greek rationality and all
of the civilization that's flourished in
the mediterranean
it can't just be brushed away and then
there's the clinical evidence coming in
from griffith's end
showing that does appear to be
positively transformative
i mean just it it points to something
that we just don't understand at all and
then
i've read a fair bit about mushrooms and
they're very very strange things
paul stamets who's i imagine you're
familiar with his work he's quite the
genius and a very strange person
i should really interview him he's he's
a remarkable person
and mushrooms are very very complicated
things and
it isn't obvious why psilocybin
mushrooms produce psilocybin doesn't
seem to do much for the mushroom
and so there's a mystery there and
well and then there's all of the
speculation that
mckenna i met his brother at a
conference on aw he came and spoke up at
the u of t so that was extremely
interesting
but his stoned ape theory is extremely
interesting as well you know i mean it's
definitely on the fringe ends of
speculation but
but um it's not like there's
any shortage of evidence that every
human culture that ever existed did
everything they possibly could to
identify
every hallucinogenic substance within
reach and become masters of them
so right well we co-evolve with these
things i love talking to paul and to
dennis
dennis mckenna um they're they're
they're great stewards of this of this
tradition um
and i you know i'm not um a mycologist
or a scientist for that matter
uh but this this is the kind of stuff
that that asks deep questions about our
past i mean so and when we're talking
about pagan continuity maybe we should
say
anthropological continuity um this this
goes because that's farther back than
pagan by
tens of thousands of years right we have
no idea how far back this goes
it could be tens of thousands of years
likely it's highly likely
i cite one study in my book about
neanderthals this is from a decade ago
they found
medicinal plants like chamomile and
yarrow in the dental calculus of
neanderthal bones in spain
um that goes back 50 000. there's some
evidence that chimps use medicinal
plants and cats eat grass when they're
ill like i mean
the relationship between animals and
plants is extraordinarily complicated
and
and and you know the thing is too the
farther back you go in history to
identify
something and you see it there the
farther back it's likely that that
occurred because the farther back you go
the more stable cultures are and the
less likely they are to have radically
transformed
so if you go back 15 000 years and
something's there well you can make a
pretty good guess that maybe it was
there 80 000 years ago because there
just wasn't that much
change and lack of change is
what's typical rather than change you
know despite our current culture
so yeah so this stuff goes way as back
as far as we can possibly imagine
you said just moments ago that
we co-evolved with mushrooms and so what
can you elaborate on that a bit
what do you mean well they certainly
precede us
um the plants go back about 470 million
years
if you talk to paul stamets he will say
there's a fossilized mushroom that's two
and a half billion years old so the
mushroom actually far precedes the
plants that we know of
uh 391 000 species 80 000 of which might
be edible
this is in orders of millions of years
before us um and let's i mean let's just
think about it commonsensically
um you know if if we weren't made to
interact with our environment why would
these plants have
an impact on us why are we equipped with
cb1 cb2 receptors
why are we equipped with the 5-ht2a
receptor why do these things have any
impact us
on us whatsoever um it seems it seems
that we've co-evolved together with our
planet
um and just maybe we're not aliens to it
but
together um these things are are more
allies than foes
in some cases poisons though they may be
yeah well that's the question are they
allies or foes and if they're allies
what exactly does that
what exactly is the significance of that
hello dr ruck it's a pleasure to meet
you and thank you very much for agreeing
to
come and talk with me we've been talking
obviously about about brian's book
and about co-evolution with mushrooms
and about the potential significance of
whatever the potential significance is
of the fact that our
religious ideas which seem to sit at the
basis of our culture
may have been profoundly influenced
across thousands of years by
hallucinogenic use and
what in the world are we supposed to
make of that and i won't read the intro
because i've already done that so we
that that people are already
informed as to who you are i'm going to
start by asking you about
uh the road to allison so you
co-authored the if that's okay can we
start there does that sound reasonable
to you
why not jump right in hey you
co-authored the road to lucius in
1978 with r gordon wesson and albert
hoffman
wasson was an amateur mycologist i
believe that his primary occupation i
think he was a banker but he was a very
accomplished
um thinker and and explorer and
he found banking very boring he told me
well it's certainly compared to the
other things he did it was it was very
run-of-the-mill uh
occupation um and he wrote this famous
book
soma which which which is well accepted
now i think
as an authoritative authoritative
hypothesis at least that
the um ancient hindus in particular were
using amanita muscaria the flygarrick
the red
mushroom with white dots the fairy tale
mushroom as an entheogen
in your terminology and
albert hoffman who discovered lsd and
you co-authored this book the rhode
tuloisis in 1978 and so
first of all like what was that like
and why did they pick you and and then
we can get into what the consequences of
that were
well actually i had a sabbatical year
and
decided i would travel across
europe so i bought a car in london and
then
shipped it over to the mainland and
drove
to greece but while i was in london
i thought i should buy books to have to
read
while i was traveling and so
i noticed a copy of john allegro's
sacred mushroom the cross in a bookstore
window and i put it in the car
and in that time that i was traveling
and staying in greece
i read it and i read it naively i was
unaware of the fact that i was not
supposed to like it
uh and
but i was i couldn't judge
where allegro was dealing with uh hebrew
or with sumerian but i
certainly could judge when he cited
classical sources
and i was amazed that he brought my
attention
things that i had not been taught
okay so i'm going to interrupt you there
just for one second if you don't mind we
were just talking about
the sacred mushroom in the cross i read
that when i was about 15 or 16 and
it completely blew the top of my head
off and of course i was completely
incapable of assessing it apart from the
fact that it looked to be
a very scholarly work and was hard to
just ignore
but but it's interesting to hear you say
that even when he moved out of his area
of specialty
into your area specialty you found him
to be a credible scholar who
who had actually found things that you
didn't know about his citations were
fantastic
and i was i was interested in dionysus
and
uh he was giving me information about
the nature of the mania induced by
possession by dionysus and
uh and so i
when i came back from the the trip i
wrote two scholarly essays
that were accepted in reputable journals
peer journals and uh published
and then i i became aware of gordon
watson's work
and read his work on
selma and a friend said why don't you
send your essays to gordon
and so i did and so i present
uh i didn't mean to but i presented
myself to watson
as an authority already on this topic
um so i always thought that he over
estimated my abilities uh
but i almost immediately got a phone
call from him he was coming to boston
and we had to meet so we did and then
the second time very shortly after
he came to boston and he said we met in
dick schulte's office this time
first time we had met we met at a
restaurant
and um he
announced to uh schulte's without having
told me
that he and i were going to work on
lucius and had to do with the grain
goddess
and schulte is being a botanist he said
oh grain very interesting
and but that's the first i knew that we
were going to work together and so
please go ahead we were going to drive
to his
his house in western
connecticut and so on the drive he told
me what the project was
and he essentially dropped in my lap
yet he had the theory that it would be
ergot
it was a sensible theory because it
would have to be something connected
with grain and the nature of
the the experience of the most
classicists would not
have accepted it uh was visionary
which would mean what in those days we
would have called hallucination but come
to know better that we shouldn't call it
that uh
it is a transcendent vision but it had
to be something connected with grain
and the most uh obvious
uh intoxicant that that would be a
toxin if you wish connected with grain
would be ergot
which was a fungus that grows on on
mushroom now
watson was always interested only in
mushrooms
because of the the experience
what he which he describes many times
of his uh honeymoon in the catskills
where he went for a walk with his wife
new wife valentina pavlovna
and she saw mushrooms growing everywhere
and he saw only toadstools
and that's why they became interested
and just got
in discovering that people had definite
attitudes about mushrooms
that they figure prominently in
in art and literature and so he was
really only interested in mushrooms and
was
i remember when we received
a specimen of aragon from hofmann
that had fruited um the skorosha
is just it looks just like a kernel of
grain that's become
clubby and and purplish um
the infected the the the real mushroom
is the root-like growth which is called
the sclerosis
and it permeates its house but under
suitable conditions
it fruits and this is true of
of ergot and so that we had uh
we didn't have the actual specimen we
had a photograph from hoffman
of the fruiting uh kernel of grain and
you could see that
mushrooms were sprouting out of it so he
was ecstatic it was indeed
we of course fungus is a fungus but
this wasn't mold this was a as he called
a higher form of
mushroom that produced the fruiting
bodies so
he was ecstatic but he it was my task
and it seemed very plausible to
i really didn't know anything about the
elusives and
mysteries uh it's peripheral to
ordinary classical education it was my
task
to show that uh yes it fit
the uh the mythological uh scenario
and when you say okay i have three
questions you you distinguish between
hallucinogen and visionary experience
and
then you also just yep please because
hallucinogen
means that you've lost your way and
you're wandering
and uh and it is pejorative
you're only you're hallucinating uh i
mean if i saw god
and someone said you're hallucinating
the person is saying you haven't seen
god you've
you've imagined something probably uh
devilish and so for that reason
i was asked to come up with a new term
and invented the term entheogen which is
actually a greek
greek adjective uh describing the way
the devotees of
dionysus became when they were possessed
by him it means you have
the deity within you and i just coined
it uh
up onto oestrogen and added the the
genesis
it's quite a coinage because it is very
different from hallucinogen or
hallucination i mean
lsd and psilocybin have been given to
people who are schizophrenic who do have
hallucinations and
the lsd and psilocybin do not exacerbate
schizophrenic hallucinations they seem
you if you want to exacerbate
schizophrenic hallucinations you use
amphetamines a different class of drugs
entirely
and so whatever it is the visionary
experiences that these
this alternative class of drugs is
producing does look pharmacologically
distinct
um in theogen obviously has
well it's an interesting word because it
actually caught on people use it it's
not that easy to coin a word
there needs to be a space for it and a
demand for it and
it has to be poetically apt so you
captured something
but in theogen obviously has a whole set
of connotations that are very much
unlike hallucinogen and yes you
mentioned the god within so
you were thinking about all these things
when you came up with the word so so
maybe you could tell me about that well
about the the connotations of
anti-aging in fact it does
it does prejudice one to accept that the
vision is in some way related to
religion
and so i have worked with uh scientists
who objected
and i co-authored a paper with him
and uh he wouldn't use the word anthogen
but
we use the word neurotropic means it
just changes the way
your brain works without judging whether
what what what what the significance of
that change is
and so it definitely it definitely is a
term that it
is used by people who believe there is
something like a spiritual dimension to
our existence and well let me ask you
about that you've been thinking about
this for an extraordinarily long time
and it's cost you a fair bit to think
about it although i imagine it's been an
adventure as well are you still pleased
with the coinage were you pleased with
the coinage of in theogen to begin with
the word and
do you stand by that that that creation
so does yes yes because of its roots it
goes into
uh european languages and so
you find it in french and german and
and so on slight adaptations to make it
fit their language but
it's the same word so
what do you what's your impression of
the validity
significance meaning etc of the in
theogenic experience what sense do you
make out of it the fact that this
chemically induced
uh this a chemical induction of a
mystical experience
what sense do you make of that what
significance is there in that the
the the what what i make of it is quite
profound but it's not something that
really one can share easily but i i can
make
i can i can put it very simply
that as as we each sit in our present
rooms
we have constructed what we consider to
be the reality by the things that we see
and we have not constructed that reality
by the things that we don't see
but it's quite obvious that what we see
is only those things that our
organs of perception allow us to react
to
uh and so anything that we are not
capable of
reacting to with our organs of sensation
isn't part of a reality and
you can train yourself to see the
fringes
of reality well
as a matter of fact the the rather
humorous event
i was at a conference with dick schultz
and
albert hoffman and nick schulte is the
botanist at harvard who had
participated in many shamanic
experiences
had taken many drugs the people in the
audience
said someone in the audience said what
has it meant for you to have taken all
those drugs
and schulte is i'm sure he was lying but
he was a very
common sense sane person
he he said means nothing means
absolutely nothing it means the next
morning you get up and go to work
and then they asked albert and albert
said
well it i think it means that the
the the the the defining lines of
reality are a bit fuzzy
a bit fuzzy so i mean as i sit here
there are
i can imagine and and it and certain
gifted times perhaps i even can respond
to the fact
there are a lot of other things going on
in this in this chamber
and where you are also
so brian i talked a bit to brian about
the
elusivian mysteries and the and the
idea that he opened his book with that
to overcome death you have to experience
death and griffith's work with
psilocybin has showed that cancer
patients who take psilocybin and have a
mystical experience have a profoundly
altered
relationship with death a profoundly
altered understanding of death and
this would be associated with those
chambers of mystery that you just
described that can be opened under some
circumstances
do you have anything to say about that
transformation and attitude towards
death which
you know seems like a highly relevant
issue all things considered since we all
have to face
death i think i think it's sad
that one should be aware of that
totality of existence only when you're
about to leave it
and what what do you think if anything
that the in theogenic experience can
contribute to
our what would you say our ability to
tolerate our mortality
our ability to understand it our ability
to transcend it
well we're talking about something
that's unknowable
and by definition that means that
anything you say about it
can't be it because it's unknowable uh
both can only speak in paradigms and in
parallels and so forth
but it is
perhaps um an outrageous supposition
to assume that we are mortal
and why do you say that why do you think
that's an outrageous supposition
and believe me i'm not trying to trap
you i'm genuinely curious about
the whole the whole mystery of being in
in procreation
is inexplicable
yeah well it certainly seems to be that
consciousness itself is inexplicable we
don't have a good causal theory for
consciousness we have no
way we have no understanding whatsoever
the relationship
between consciousness and neurological
functioning as far as i've been able to
tell i've read a lot of books on
consciousness and neurology and
most of them aren't particularly
credible some of them are good but
there's there's also a mystery about the
fact of existence it's
experiential existence itself which is
obviously dependent on consciousness and
what we do not don't know about
consciousness can fill many many volumes
and
so that speaks to your many chambered
experiential realm arguments
what happened okay let's talk about
hoffman because you wrote the book
you wrote wrote two letters with hoffman
as well so you talked about west song
how did you meet hoffman
i uh only met him at
that conference with schulte's and then
again i met him on his 100th
birthday at a conference
in basel and i hadn't seen him for
30 years i mean well i'd seen him
i guess in the 80s i hadn't seen him for
a couple of decades
and he didn't recognize me when i got up
to speak i was announced
and he said oh carl is that you
well that's a long time yes i just saw
one of my colleagues a
week ago or so a couple of weeks ago i
hadn't seen him for 20 years and i
wouldn't have recognized him 25 years i
wouldn't have recognized him if i would
have passed him on the street
i don't know if he would have recognized
me either so that's a long that's a long
time
so can you can you briefly outline the
thesis of the road to a loyalist
it
the thesis is very simple it was for
one of many
what returned termed mystery initiations
in antiquity but in the case of
this mystery initiation it was first of
all
a panhellenic
right so many people
uh not just from a village or
a tribal group of greece uh or you
didn't even have to be greek
anyone who had the means to do it uh
would do what was considered the
experience of a lifetime
and so it was a kind of universal
experience but it was only one of many
of these things which were performed
locally and it was institutionalized
which is very interesting so
because brian and i were talking about
the reintroduction of psychedelics into
the west in the 1960s of course that
caused
tremendous cultural disruption and then
clamped down on the use of psychedelics
in general but the greeks had figured
out
how to institutionalize their use and to
well maybe the greeks had maybe the
precursors to the greeks had because god
only knows how old the tradition was but
they seem to be able to keep the genie
in the bottle so to speak and do you
have any sense of how they manage that
athens was was becoming an imperial
power and
and ended next to lucius and then took
over the
the uh the religion and so athens wasn't
origin as as the religion as the
right became more popular
of course people knew about it but there
was no reason
lucius was a separate town a separate
state
there was no reason why it would be
identified with athens other than the
fact that athens
next to lucis and then took over
the administration of the of the rights
and in fact um
had a preliminary right which was
performed in athens a half year
before the the right at that village and
it was
this is about 14 miles outside of athens
to the
to the west so but in the case of
but in the case of elusive which makes
it so interesting not only was it this
important uh classical mystery religion
but the others which were equally
important in this case
we have in homeric
him to the goddess
of demeter these are poems in the style
of homer but not by homer
in homeric type of poetry we have the
precise
uh ingredients for a potion that was
drunk
as part of it of the mystery and
of course you could just disregard it as
classes as have
as meaning nothing or you could think
that it was responsible
for the fact that people we know what
happened
uh although it can't be believed what
happened and as i said it's unknowable
so what i'm saying isn't what happened
but they um they all saw something at
exactly the same
time in a chamber after they've been
prepared
for by long indoctrination as what they
were supposed to see
and so forth um but on youtube
they saw something and you do you see
that as a continuation of the shamanic
tradition
yes of course yes there's no there's no
way
you can make a group of people several
thousand people
see something all at the same time by
drumming or fasting or anything of that
kind it's going to be
haphazard some people may uh have a
transcendent experience and others won't
but
on cue every year a large group of
people
uh had a vision after they
drank a a a potion whose ingredients
are known
do you have some sense of the of the
contents of the vision
yeah can can you outline that
i can quote because of course to
to say what it was openly was prohibited
under the pain of death but um
in in a play of euripides the ion
the coral says that when you
pass through the gates of the hall
of initiation you will
see the stars dance and with them
dance the moon but i have to remind you
that the hall of initiation has a solid
roof
you cannot see the sky the only way you
can see the stars
dance and with them dance the moon is if
you have transcended
the physical past to the edge of the
cosmos which is what is described in
ancient poems of the shamanic journey to
the
to the edge of the cosmos and are there
dancing amongst the celestial
uh bodies the planets and the stars
okay let let me ask you a science first
that's impossible isn't it
yeah well yeah who knows what's
impossible precisely
this was described over and over again
though it's what plato describes in the
feeders
it's what parmenides describes in his
poem
in in the shamanic tradition at least
according to iliad and to other sources
that i've read
the the shaman who although eliade
didn't accept this part of the
hypothesis because he didn't accept the
hallucinogenic the centrality of
hallucinogenic substances in the
shamanic experience but
we talked about that earlier in the
podcast but the the
the shamanic initiate a shamanic
practitioner
would die would be reduced to a skeleton
that's one way of think
thinking about one one part of the
experience
and and sometimes have his body organs
replaced or sometimes have them replaced
by something that represented a
crystalline structure that was more pure
but would die anyways
would reliably commune with the
ancestors
would then leave the cosmos as we know
it
traveling up and down something like
layers of
like a structure that represented the
different layers of experience which
seemed to me something like
imagine the standard three three
dimensions of reality
plus time so we've got width and height
and depth
and time but there's there's another
dimension of sorts which is
the dimension that we experience when we
go down into the micro realm of being
and that
when we experience when we go up into
the macro realm of being
so from the subatomic to the
cosmological level that seems to me to
be portrayed by
the idea of the world tree you can see
that in scandinavian mythology because
the
world tree is associated with the cosmos
as such and then
the ability to move up and down that
tree seems to be associated with the
ability to move between the earthly
realm and the heavenly realm
and to move into the heavenly realm is
to move outside of the normal cosmos
which is reminiscent to me of the idea
that
god the christian idea that god exists
in a place and
that and time that's outside of our
universe so
it's it's which is quite a remarkable
and
non-obvious idea um
this so why am i i'm wondering to what
degree that
idea that cosmological idea of the world
tree is associated with this idea of the
journey through the cosmos and the
and the experience of divinity in the
ellucian mysteries is that a variant of
the
shamanic story i mean everything that
you've been saying
is documentable also in in classical
mythology
these are themes which are waiting for
scholars to recognize but
and they are now but when i
embarked in the study of classics there
were very few classes who even knew
that uh these things were being spoken
of okay which things are you
referring to well like the body being
uh being attacked by uh demons and
spirits and
and the internal organs being
rearranged in a a police a page
a part of the body replaced with some
badge of immortality
all of the descendants of peel ups you
see you see that here
something flashed into my mind i'm an
admirer of the disney film pinocchio
yeah now pinocchio goes down to the
depths right he's an initiate
he goes down to the depths he goes down
to the bottom of the ocean like
gilgamesh
yes he finds his father that's the
ancestral spirits in the body of a
dragon it's a whale but that whale
breathes fire it's a dragon
for all intents and purposes and when
he's transformed
into a genuine person right and so
that's his rebirth and transformation he
comes back from the dead
his conscience jiminy cricket is given a
gold badge
and that's an echo of that shamanic idea
of the replacement of something
the soul-like it reflects the stars
actually that's how the movie closes
this badge reflects the stars so you see
these
unbelievably deep classical mythological
slash shamanic ideas popping up in
places that you'd never expect them to
pop up continually and constantly
that i mean what you're talking about is
a subject for a whole
uh another series of your investigations
it's
it's um what the disney artists knew
about
anthogenic or do now know about
anthogenic experience
because they fit the pattern perfectly
yeah so and so do you have any specific
knowledge of that i mean that movie was
made in the 1930s
number i mean it's a work of absolute
genius that that
that movie is so deep it just stuns me
every time i watch it because there's
always something more to discover in it
and
but in fantasia isn't there an uh an
episode of
dancing uh mushrooms yes
i believe there is that's incredible no
i know i mean it must have been crazy no
one would know what that meant
yeah yeah there has been an inner core
of people that know very well what it
all means
so what happened to you after this book
was published first of all what did you
expect would happen when you published
this book that's the first question
and then what actually happened i
expected that other classicists
would take the idea and
work with it in fields of expertise that
i
did not master i expected that they
would
they would take the ball and run with it
but um like you did with allegro's book
yeah
but uh it didn't happen and in
particular
uh my situation at boston university
was that at the time i was acting
chairman
and president silver
was a a great supporter of classics but
he had his own idea of what classics
were and i worked with him in fact in in
in
starting the build-up of the department
which has become quite a respected
department
um but uh he had his own idea
about what he would have thought drugs
and and his idea of greek rationality
he was a philosopher and so he
certainly was not willing even though
dodds had written a book on greeks and
the irrational
irrational which greatly influenced me
he was not
one of those people that was interested
in greek irrationality
and so i was at a chairman's meeting
in his his office and he was
talking to us about we had to stress the
fact that
publications were necessary for
advancement
and then he looked at me and he said
unless it's a publication
by the vanity press and i
i had nothing to do with the publication
and harcourt brace was not a vanity
press
and watson didn't pay for the
publication
so that that would be with the
definition of
vanity presses and braces certainly not
a vanity press i mean there's no doubt
about that
helen wolfe um her son
i was very interested in the work he's
the classicist
and she was our particular editor um
but uh i was labeled as
publishing with vanity press and he
disliked me from that point on
well and do you you believe it was
because why because of his
his belief well he was the rationality
particularly the rationality of the
greek not the dionysian element
yes absolutely uh and he was a very
divisive figure
and so it became um
a way for people who wanted to advance
themselves
to denigrate me so i had
colleagues in my department who turned
against me because
that way they could climb up on my
corpse and and
and promote themselves it's all changed
now i mean the people
who were involved are no longer there
except for a few people
who are my friends and i'm not they're
not hostile with me at all now
but it was a very divisive period at
boston university
and to put to put carl's experience in
context maybe this is
in the late 1970s one of carl's
colleagues at the time was
howard zinn who famously wrote the
people's history of the united states
published in
in 1980 you know john silber who was the
president
of bu at the time this sort of no
nonsense no nonsense texan of
conservative presbyterian roots
um he didn't have the best relationship
with howard zinn either
uh he would deny the the marxist as he
called him sabbaticals promotions and
pay raises
um and you know silver was no fan of the
anti-war movement
or revolutionaries and the idea of you
know aligning the psychedelic gospels of
enlightenment from tim leary and others
with this with this anti-war movement
was not was not welcome on campus in the
late 70s
or to suspect that a faculty member was
going to
introduce students to drugs which of
course not
anywhere in the realm of possibility
right but there i guess there's that
that the
what would you say the uncertain
consequence of
taking this sort of hypothesis seriously
right which
is an uncertain there are uncertain
causes it's a very
dangerous it's a very dangerous
proposition because
it opens up the possibility that
religious
experience or spiritual realities are
a part of our basic nature as as humans
well and that is what it's called that
calls into question the validity of all
the religions
it's it's so well i think it's worse i
think it calls
it it opens up the possibility that
they're correct
they're correct they have just defined
it in their own
well yes yes that yes but i i think
i think the idea this might be my own
personal pacadillo but i think the idea
that
there's something in the central
religious doctrine that's fundamentally
correct is much more terrifying than the
idea that there isn't
that's how it looks to me i mean if if
there's something divine and immortal
about human beings and
it's our ultimate ethical responsibility
to let that shine into the world
and that's part of reality itself then
you know heaven help us when we don't
manage that that's how it looks to me
and yes absolutely you know i've heard
freudian criticisms of
of religious belief for example know
that that the
belief in life after death is nothing
but a myth
that's designed to what would you say
keep us in
childhood denial of the terrible
realities of our experi
of existence but you know that doesn't
really account for the
prevailing stories of hell let's say
because if you're going to invent a
religion that does nothing but satisfy
your childish delusions why would you
bother with hell and there's this
element
to the religious yes go ahead i could
challenge you to prove that you're alive
you're just hallucinating my god you
really are off the wall
well there's no doubt about that but but
i get your point well
so so i'm not sure what i don't i'm not
exactly sure what the more revolutionary
idea is you know is that
and there's another part of this that's
extraordinarily problematic too from a
philosophical perspective which is that
if the entheogens are pointing towards
something that resembles a genuine
religious experience and if that
religious experience is
profound and valid and constitutes part
of the base from which our culture both
greek and christian was derived let's
say rather than being antithetical to it
in this dionysius versus apollo way
if it's actually at the core of it which
is the case brian makes for example in
his book
then this is all something that we need
to take extraordinarily seriously and
that's really revolutionary as far as
i'm concerned
and and now we have a chemical you know
because part of the problem for
for for western people has always been
well we've got the material realm in
science and look at how powerful it is
we have the spiritual realm and
it's separate but all of a sudden now
you have something that bridges the gap
right which is these strange psychedelic
chemicals which are
material in the utmost but have this in
intense
spiritual what would you say
nature or at least are capable of of
eliciting that in us
and so then that calls into question the
entire relationship between the material
structure of existence and the spiritual
realm and that's revolutionary
i was talking to a physicist last week
um
unfortunately his name momentarily
escapes my mind but he's a famous
atheist and
i mentioned griffith's work to him you
know it's like
well he he's he's one of the people who
originated the idea that the entire
universe could spring into being from
nothing and
as elementary particles do and
he sees no materialist evidence
whatsoever for a spiritual realm but
then
i said well what what do you do with
griffith's work what do you do with the
entire
corpus of psychedelic experience what do
you make of that because
ignoring it isn't going to help there's
the shamanic tradition
there's the the continuation of that
into greece and the illusionian
mysteries there's the development of
that throughout christianity
that can't just be easily set aside
especially if
rescue is right for example and there
was some influence
of these sacramental potions on the
development
of early christian ideas and those ideas
are central to our culture
yes so we've got a big problem here
conceptually
and it's no one i i would say it's
actually a testament to the integrity of
the universities that something as
revolutionary as what you did
didn't completely destroy your career
it's true yeah uh it
at the time i had several students who
were
writing the dissertation so i'm not
imagining that
this event happened they were told that
they
could not um they would never get
their degree unless they dropped me as
as their
adviser and they remain my friends and
and that's the story they told me and
their
their work uh was then um
finished by other people and uh
in some cases that have been quite
successful
they've been published and so forth but
it was the work they did with me
and was stolen by somebody else because
because and this and this was not the
silver who did it was someone in the
department
who was definitely trying to get
get credits for what he was doing
who stole the students away from me
well it's it's it's heartening to me
that you were able to
maintain your career as an academic
despite wandering into this most
uh incendiary territory
and i'm not sure that that would be the
case today at least under some
circumstances so
um i'm going to blame all these
questions on brian by the way because he
said
to me so but they're good questions so
i'm going to go ahead with them
you apparently tested the cookie on
potion
yourself in the 1970s albert hoffman
sent you and was on some ergot in the
mail
could you share that story yeah just
rather humorous because
we did do it
it was at the very beginning in fact
because watson was very direct
if we were going to write about this uh
we should know what the experience was
like
and so it was one of the times that i
visited him about once a month i went to
spend the weekend at his house in
connecticut
and as we were driving there
he said uh we're going to take the
potion tonight
and so oh really and we had
dinner his his old nanny
was there uh an elderly black woman
and uh he announced we're gonna take
the potion tonight and this is awfully
open because
you know i believe this is illegal to be
taking drugs
and it's so he said
the custom is to fast before you
do this and so we can't eat anything so
we sat there while the other people ate
and then when dinner was over we got up
to go down to the
the barn in the studio he stayed in this
his studio which was converted in
in the barn not in the main house
and as we got to go uh the other people
said we'll have fun
that was this is rather flippant too so
when we
got there he put on some music and he
said
the custom is to observe silence so i
knew that i wasn't supposed to talk i
didn't know at the time but we were
listening to the chanting of maria
sabina the mazatec shaman
i said it was very moving and we sat
wrapped up in
blankets by the fireplace
his daughter who was a
phd in nursing uh
sat in the corner as as the monitor in
case anything went wrong
and so no one spoke and chanting went on
about midnight i finally said gordon i
don't think anything has happened
and he said yes yes it's been most
disappointing
but we were hungry because we went up to
the house and raided the pantry and had
something to eat the next morning
we took out albert's letter in which he
gave a very detailed account
of what he had experienced with this
potion
so we just decided well um apparently it
works it doesn't work for us we didn't
take enough of it
and so um we went ahead with it
on the basis of albert's experience not
our own
gordon said albert's a very small man he
didn't send enough for people our size
and and what was that was the potion
an lsd derivative was it purified lsd no
it was ergonovine which was one of the
chemicals in ergot
and at the time uh we had
settled up on that because um
it was the aragon has has some 300
toxins
it's very complicated chemical
uh complex but only one of them is water
soluble and that's ergonovine
and so by simple extraction
in in water which is what's required for
the recipe in the homeair kim
we could get ergonovine but
other people have tried it since and
ergonomic doesn't seem to
be that active but i've worked with
peter uh webs webster
in france who's a chemist and
we have decided to discover that
ergotamine which is what's marketed for
migraines that dilates the the
blood vessels in the brain and treats
migraines
ergotamine in itself is
is not a psychoactive but
in a aqueous solution
which is alkaline and
the achieving of making it alkaline is
simple you just add some bone ash to it
and that would fit
also the scenario of the significance
of the mythological paradigm of the
illustrion mystery so it has to be
something simple like that
um some bone ash and that produces an
alkaline solution
and then ergonoming goes into
a uh it's it's not
a solution but it's called hydrolysis
which is a combination with water
something like what happens when you
chew on starches in your mouth
and it it it is an unstable
chemical of itself in this mirror image
going back and forth between the two
constantly
and that apparently is psychoactive
so the the the this the potion that you
took
with wausau wasn't effective
what about other experiences that you've
had if you want to talk about them and
you're certainly not obligated to
um yes of course anything that was done
and unless
in those days narco tourism was not
the vogue and anyone can do this now
uh legally by traveling and to
south america or to mexico and there's
quite a a tourist trade
in that sort of thing but in those days
it was illegal to have access to these
substances and
so whatever experience i had was
given by friends who had gotten them
unfortunately from
the illegal drug trade so but i i
i did have experience with lsd with
psilocybin and did you have a classic
shamanic experience with those
substances
yes very intense and did it involve
dying it involved
i mean it's very hard to talk about this
because if i talk about it and
some people will think i'm a religious
leader and i'll have a following and
they want me to
establish a church and well all that
sort of well that's yeah
do you have you ever read relations
between the ego and the unconscious by
carl jung
just out of curiosity i have yes okay
okay okay because he he he provides some
psychological hygiene tips in precisely
that regard
although for him i don't know if it was
a consequence of
knowing anything about hallucinogenic
use but the reason i got
the reason i got into classics i was
originally
going to be a psychiatrist and i did
pre-med
but i had a philosophy course
at yale and the philosophy was
one of those charismatic young guys
uh he said you're studying psych
psychology psychiatry because you're
interested
in in in the soul and you think that
um psychiatry will give you access to
the soul
but uh psychiatry is
is a a doctoring a medicine uh
profession uh it deals with sick souls
uh and it's true i was really interested
in psychiatric psychiatry because i was
fascinated by
the delusional realities that were
reported in case history is not
we very much wondered what they meant
and was dying to experience
safely that kind of delusional reality
but he said if if you want to study the
soul you have to study
the humanities and so i
took seriously what he said and thought
that classics was the most basic of the
of the humanities so i switched into
classics
but i was interested in the soul to
begin with now so you're
you're a trained classicist who
experimented with psychedelic substances
so my
presupposition is that your training as
a classicist
likely influenced and expanded your
experiences with psychedelic substances
it would have provided structure and
content it gave he gave me the
uh i mean became a mythologist mythology
gives me a
framework for understanding a way of
structuring
imaginary reality in this culture okay
so can you tell me a little bit about
how you've structured your understanding
of that
imaginary did you say imaginary reality
did you say mythological reality
well if i look at it from my
sane vantage point i would call it
imagine reality but i
very much wanted to enter into the world
of myth
right but it's a strange kind of
imagination isn't it because
yes well because there's this
trans-personal element to it this is the
thing that that i can't quite understand
is that
you could describe the landscape of the
imagination is purely subjective but the
problem with that is is that
the features of the landscape are
transpersonal that's what's expressed in
mythology and if they weren't we
couldn't talk about it and so
even though it's subjective it has a
trans-personal or impersonal element
that seems to be grounded in
you can't say objective reality
precisely because you experience it
subjectively but it's not
only like idiosyncratic imagination
it has this death underworld element
this rebirth element that
so okay so i'm going to push you again
if you don't mind
i would be more interested in your take
on this you've had these experiences
you're a trained classicist
what what what is this reality that's
being laid out in these
experiences and how do you understand it
i think of it as a
journey to discover who you are
and when you you go on
there's a journey um it gets dangerous
and you
feel the maybe you should turn back but
just
up ahead it looks as though it's it
might be even more interesting up there
so you go further and further and
further
when you get to the end of the
journey what you find is yourself
looking back
there i mean i i said i'm not gonna
found your church
but there is no god
you're so stupid don't you realize you
are god
and so what
i guess what i wonder about is
what happens if you
what are the implications of that kind
of realization for how you conduct your
life like look what happens with with
griffith's
subjects they quit smoking okay so now
it's easy to think about that as a
pharmacological effect
purely right that their brains undergo a
chemical transformation they're no
longer addicted to
to to uh nicotine i don't believe that's
what happens i believe what happens is
that they undergo a mystical experience
that alerts them to who they should
and could be and that doesn't involve
poisoning themselves with a deadly
substance so
in light of the new information they've
received about
their potential and maybe the actuality
of their being
they decide to desist in that they
desist in that self-destructive pattern
of behavior
i think the same thing happens to
alcoholics that are cured so to speak as
a consequence of psychedelic experience
does that seem reasonable to you
it does seem reasonable yes but
i have to i mean we're talking
about very dangerous subject because
many of these substances
are addictive and
causing tremendous hardship for people
who get
get hooked on them uh and
even alcohol which
is legal is extremely dangerous and
there are
many people who are addicted to it and
it's clearly the most dangerous
i know people have died yes alcohol is
an absolute catastrophe i mean
there'd be virtually no violence
domestic violence for example there's no
alcohol alcohol is a catastrophe in 50
different ways
that doesn't necessarily mean it should
be illegal but yeah that's different
i mean there has to be an etiquette of
use
and and
these addictive substances you described
the hallucinogens don't technically fall
into that category
oddly enough right because people tend
not to abuse them
in the case of lsd you build up an
immediate
immunity to it so if you take it the
second day nothing happens at all
yes and something similar has been
reported with psilocybin and and with
dmt
so they seem to be self-limiting
substances at least to some degree as
opposed to drugs like cocaine which
is classic psychomotor stimulants or the
and
or or the benzodiazepine class or
which or the opiates for that matter
which all have that addictive
that addictive tendency so
um here's a question let's move away
from the personal experience and a bit
although i
i'm so attempted to to push it deeper
but i won't i'll leave it be for the
time being
what was the this is something i did
discuss with brian
his his book he's obviously profoundly
influenced by you his book
i believe is predicated on the
assumption that
greek the great greek rationality
everything that we admire
and understand about greek culture was
embedded inside this mystical tradition
it wasn't antithetical to it it was
embedded inside it yes
like our thought is embedded inside a
dream if you think about it from a
jungian perspective
which and i think that's an accurate way
of looking at the world rationality
embedded in a dream embedded in the body
said something like that what do you
think was the value of non-ordinary
states of consciousness in classical
antiquity
uh the value for us
is that we would not have the great
works of sculpture
and literature and
painting if
the if that society did not have
access to this awareness of spiritual
entities
okay so can i thank you but they call it
the muses
but i mean but but they're not imaginary
they're actually possessing spirits the
people uh testify over and over again
that in the act of creation and i find
that
my side you know i'm just writing an
essay in the act of creation you don't
know what you're doing
someone is working through you something
is working through you
or if i don't want to go that far
it allows me to to reconfigure
the functioning of my brain in a way
that ordinarily would not have access
to
there is a this idea of the communion
with the
the ancestors seems to me to be
analogous on the shamanic front to the
idea of being possessed by the creative
spirit that drives
mankind essentially is that the the
the experience that's induced by the
psychedelics that puts
the users in touch with their ancestors
puts them in touch
that's exactly the right way to think
about it i think with with the central
animating spirit of
of mankind and that's part of that's
that spirit that drives that
continual conversation that
that we're all supposed to be involved
in for example as humanities
practitioners right the golden chain
that
exists down the centuries that stretches
all the way back to the shamanic rituals
that's all part of this and that's the
spirit that emanate animates you
when you're creative and animates means
to be possessed by a spirit because it's
related to anima
right and so you are possessed by a
benevolent spirit that produces
and utters truth if you're engaged in
the creative activity
properly and i those psychedelics
that that mystical experience seems to
be associated with the ability to
move away the blinders that would stop
you
from being able to perceive the
existence of that spirit that's
it yes that's reasonable yes it isn't
reasonable at all
of course none of this is the least bit
reasonable ellwood
had just had synthesized lsd five years
before he was aware
of its visionary potential
um but at the time it didn't seem to
have any
uh use and so he put it aside
on a shelf in his laboratory and five
years later as he was passing the shelf
he sensed that the vial said
take me and so he took it off the shelf
and took the smallest amount
assuming that it would be too small to
be deadly
poisonous or to have any effect and he
would work his way up to see what its
effect might be
and so the smallest conceivable those
who produced
the first lsd documented trip in our in
our area well is it still the case
when i was studying pharmacology to the
degree that i studied it
that the claim was made that lsd is the
most potent pharmacological substance
ever discovered that a hundred million
molecules or some tiny trivial amount
is sufficient to induce a mystical state
it's unbelievably potent
and now maybe there have been
pharmacological agents discussed
unaware that maybe some new things but
then yeah that's what i understand too
it's extra extraordinary
here's a question brian came up with as
well if the ancient greeks used drugs to
find god so what why should anybody care
about
this today what are you really looking
for in this research
well i guess that's a reasonable set of
questions
what about jung what about jung do you
think that he do you think that he
experimented with hallucinogens
who carl jung because he knew things he
knows things that you just can't believe
anybody could know
we know he he spent a year in in taos
i have a house in taos
and um that year is not documented but
he was experimenting with with the
mind-altering substances
psilocybin probably
was that before or after the red book do
you know i think the red book came out
of that
how sure are you that that happened
well i can't be sure yeah i know i know
because
i wasn't there and um
one could try to find it if there are
any people who knew him at the time
um but he had a strange family
background there were lots of
visionaries in his family so he might
have been
one of those spontaneously visionary
types like what about william blake
i that that's one of the things that um
we're very interested in tracking down
the the use of anthogens
amongst people reputable great
monuments of our cultural tradition
did they have access to altered
consciousness and i'm quite sure that
blake did
milton well
each one of these is a whole study i
know i might
yes yes so i i don't know i can't come
up with a
passage in milton but it's certainly it
would be
a fertile thing to to do it's
it's it's one of the things on the
agenda for
brian me and my other associates
brian you said when we were talking that
you hadn't tried anything that was
psychedelic despite your intense
interest and so i'm going to be
nosy and rude and ask you what's
stopped you hmm
maybe i've been influenced by carl's
story too much
it's um you must be dying of curiosity i
just said that you are so curious his
testimony is
all the more valuable because he hasn't
done it so people cannot say that he's
ruined his mind on drugs
so that if he does do it he should keep
it secret
um well that's part of i mean you know
um i would take a lie detector today
i still have not done it um i i'm dying
of curiosity i wanted to approach
this book in as objective a manner as
possible i do i do
i do think that's important but it's not
off the table for the future what i've
said in the past is
um and i mentioned this earlier jordan i
don't think that psychedelics are
mutually exclusive of organized faith
or or traditional faith and um
carl and i were both raised catholic as
a matter of fact um
and you know there's there's a version
there's a way of doing this that
that is both i think um honest and
respectful of the ancient mysteries the
pagan mysteries
and paleochristianity i keep coming back
to those first few centuries after jesus
as this ancient culture if we can't if
we can't integrate christianity let's
say with
with its precursors how the hell are we
going to integrate christianity with the
rest of the world
and this might be a way as odd as that
sounds or you know
mysticism writ large and you see this
all over the catholic religious orders
from the franciscans to the jesuits and
carthusians i mean
there there's a periphery to
christianity where
mysticism lives and breathes the the
same mysticism
i would argue as as the ancient
mysteries psychedelic or otherwise and
so if there was a vehicle
a container for this it would it would
be in that periphery
the the meister eckhart periphery you
know where to if you could not yourself
for an instant
um you know you would possess all right
the dogma the dogma
generally speaking has to be the
container for the mystical experience
too you know i mean people who have a
spiritual bent
who are on the openness and
personality-wise let's say
of the religious continuum they tend to
be antithetical to dogma but dogma
contains the tradition that
constrains and i suppose in some sense
delimits the insanity of the psychedelic
mystical experience
those two things have to be brought
together and i think it has a way of
interpreting the experience too i i i've
asked carl in the past
what should i be doing to prepare for my
first psychedelic trip
and he's told me you've done it it's in
the study of classics as we were talking
about before
um i'm not sure if that's true or not uh
but you know the
when it comes to psychedelics it's a
framework for
you know disentangling and well there's
an ethical idea too you know i mean
before the
before the ancient hebrews encountered
the god of the
ark of the covenant they purified
themselves ethically
that's something to be cognizant of now
if you if the layers of reality are
peeled back and the distinction between
good and evil is drawn for you you want
to be sure you're as far away from the
malevolence in your own spirit as you
can possibly be
and that's no joke i mean that's part of
the reason that the
that set is so important because these
experiences can
become hellish in no time flat and i
suspect that's
likely more to be the case to the degree
to which there's a certain amount of
hellishness in your psyche
and so that's a warning of of sorts
um i have another question for you dr
rock i asked brian this and
if the dionysian first of all
how do you view the relationship between
this is a terribly complicated question
dionysius in christ
and why was it necessary so to speak for
dionysius to transform into christ
let me i mean just
make simple observation that that
christ is a hellenized
jewish tradition christ is
a greek deity
the christian story is a
greek myth
so you so it's the it's the con it's the
consequence of judaism and
greece coming together this does not
mean to say that it is an
authentic religion i understand okay so
let me let me ask you a question
so i studied to the degree that i'm
capable
the emergence of the uh of the god
marduk in
mesopotamian culture and one of the
things that i stumbled across was the
fact that marta
was for example known by at least 50
different names
and they were all attributes and i
thought well each of those names was
likely
at some point in history the signifier
of a tribal deity
and the tribal deity so imagine this
imagine that we abstract up what we
admire into something resembling the
deity that guides our
our tribe and we we we
attribute to that a personality and and
we try to enter into a relationship with
it because it's the personality that
represents the ideal just like the
personality that animates you when
you're creative
represents the creative spirit that
permeates mankind
each tribe has its own idealized
representation and but when tribes come
together those ideals fight that's the
battle between
gods in heaven that iliadi writes about
so so prolifically
so you imagine that as tribes come
together their gods fight in
psychological space and arrange
themselves into something resembling a
hierarchy and
a higher god emerges as a consequence of
the conflict something that's more
sophisticated
and so and so as we aggregate
as human beings as we aggregate across
tribes we develop a more sophisticated
and universal conception of the highest
ideal
so you have greece and and and and
and and judaism combined and
out of that emerges the figure of crisis
transformation of dionysius
and as you said it's not something that
it doesn't invalidate the
the revelation you'd expect some
revelation to occur as the consequence
of the
of the interaction between two cultures
that had been separated
because they had their own profound
developmental history of course it would
be cataclysmic
something has to come out of that and i
what i don't understand is the role that
the hallucinogens played in that
of course there's many things i don't
understand but that's certainly one of
them
yeah i mean the fact that religions
fight with each other the tribes have
their
their own uh contingent of deities and
and uh they fight with each other and so
on that's that's the whole tragedy of
this
because once you define it uh you try to
own it
and then you have people with their
set of belongings and opposing people
with another set of belongings
whereas the basic nature of this
experience is that
that's all the material there's only one
reality it can't be defined that way
i mean you don't have to see you don't
have to
explain these other entities that are in
this room
these rooms with us as as
animals or as animate uh
human hybrids or as humans and so forth
equally in this ancient mystery
tradition what could be seen would be
the
perfect relationships of mathematics and
geometry
and and uh we know that
uh pythagoras uh
was was uh
he he he didn't figure out with pencil
and paper
the relationship of geometric forms and
so forth
he saw it and he saw it
while he was in a cave and the way he
did
this is that in from the cave as in the
election
chamber of initiation he transcended
in the spirit out of the cave to the
edges of the universe and saw those
things of course
that's impossible he couldn't have done
that but that's
what he did well he was pythagoras after
all
yeah i know but anyway but but i mean so
we don't have to define them as
as this goddess or that that god and so
forth
we already have uh working out a a
really
great system of definitions
which we call science
right i mean even carl even scholars who
don't support the psychedelic hypothesis
necessarily
and i'm thinking of maybe peter kingsley
who's also a great inspiration
well nonetheless talk about the wisdom
yes in the dark places of wisdom or his
book reality
he gets into kingsley goes into great
detail about these cave techniques and
these incubatory techniques practiced
by pythagoras in his basement that he
built for these techniques
in italy entering into these these these
states of trance these catalytic
states of trance you know beyond time
beyond space with
this kind of apparently near-death state
um
you know this this this was practiced by
the likes of pythagoras parmenides and
pedocles
the these pre-socratics with or without
drugs um would enter into these states
to commune with the goddess and bring
back the things
that we would call at least part of
western civilization so i mean these
the these states of non-irrationality um
uh you know i think this is
relatively accepted by classicist carl
this goes back to er er dodds the greeks
and the and the irrational
a couple generations ago so i think
psychedelics are just one twist on this
gilgamesh goes down to the bottom of the
ocean like
pinocchio does and he brings back the
herb of immortality but it's stolen it's
i believe by a snake on the way back is
that that's the case is
that's the story is that a shamanic
story as well
yes and so we go out to the edge of the
world to gather wisdom but on the way
back we lose it that we can't bring it
back
or we can only bring back fragments of
it we're not capable of bringing back at
all
once you wake up it's hard to remember
the dream
that's a good place to stop
but we could add one thing yes one
very important technique is to enter the
dream world
and when you're dreaming don't decide
you want to wake up
but carry consciousness into the dream
in which case you've entered this world
you're in the spirit world you're in
control of everything
have you been able to lucid dream yes
are you an avid practitioner
i used to practice it more than i do now
because
i came to realize that what i was trying
to do was die
there's no sense in hurrying and
hurrying the process
well i mean once once you do that once
you disassociate your
spirit from your body you might decide
you don't want to go back in again
and that's that's what happens when you
die
but the moment when you do that when you
bring consciousness into your
unconscious reality
is extremely orgasmic pleasant feeling
thank you very much brian thank you
jordan much appreciated
thank you appreciate your candor
to say the least and your work for that
matter
you know you're you're participating in
something that's of staggering
significance thank you jordan
[Music]
you